Earth can be a really loud place if you’re
searching for an extraterrestrial signal.
Television broadcasts, radio transmissions,
cell phones - we’re beaming noisy signatures
of our technology into space all the time.
But we’re not the only noise maker in the
universe.
Black holes crashing into each other, fast
radio bursts, and other celestial phenomenon
create lots of astronomical background noise.
So if there are extraterrestrials out there,
how do we find the signal through all that
noise?
The question of whether or not we're alone
in the universe is a question that's been
with humanity since you know we stared up
at the sky and wondered what was out there.
But it's only been in the last about 50 or
60 years that we've had the technology and
the understanding of astrophysics in order
to really search
for these signals.
Andrew Siemion is the director of UC Berkeley
SETI Research Center.
SETI is an acronym, it stands for the Search
for Extraterrestrial Intelligence.
To find a needle in our galactic haystack,
SETI uses a network of radio telescopes to
search for alien technosignatures.
Which would look like a specific, purposeful
signal.
Technology exhibits a very high degree of
what we call coherence which means that ultimately
electrons usually move in a very regular way
through some piece of technology.
That means a signal from an extraterrestrial
would be consistent and distinct.
That property of coherence is fundamentally
the way in which we tell the difference between
a natural astrophysical object and an example
of technology.
When SETI first started we could only search
maybe 100 radio channels, maybe 200 radio
channels and we had to tune by hand.
Now today 60 years on we can search 10 billion
radio channels and we can search them instantaneously.
With recent advances in machine learning & artificial
intelligence, SETI experiments can look for
a wider class of signals, and helping sift
the data.
This is one of the biggest questions in SETI,
what part of the electromagnetic spectrum
should we search.
We have radio light followed by infrared light,
optical light, ultraviolet light, x-rays and
gamma rays.
The truth is that we don't know what part
is the best, so we operate experiments in
the radio and the infrared and the optical.
While we haven’t found a clear sign of extraterrestrial
intelligence yet, there was one notable close
call that some consider first contact — it’s
called the Wow signal.
The day after an observing run one time, one
of the scientists came in and looked at the
output from this dot matrix printer and saw
some sort of evidence of a signal on there
and draw a circle around it and wrote Wow.
Today if we saw that signal we would have
so much more data on the signal that we could
very rapidly identify it as interference.
By far the biggest challenge in radio SETI
is what we call radio frequency interference.
Because we use our own technology as an example
of what we should be looking for we in fact
find many many examples of our own technology
and those examples actually pollute the signal
that we see especially with radio telescopes.
Satellites that are whirling overhead — people
with cell phones, microwave ovens, and Wi-Fi
routers.
One of the most famous examples of radio frequency
interference in radio astronomy in the last
decade or so actually was ultimately attributed
to a microwave oven in the visitor center
of the observatory that didn't have the proper
shielding around it.
It's telling the difference between the very
very distant probably very very weak signal
from an extraterrestrial intelligence and
the incredibly numerous nearby examples of
technology that are close to the radio telescope
that get into the data.
So it remains a big challenge, but if we see
something, there are kind of very specific
tests that we can do and all the signals that
we found so far have been ruled out by those
tests.
To date, SETI has only a few thousand star
systems, out of over 100 billion stars out
there.
So the failure to find a signal through the
noise isn't evidence enough that there isn't
alien intelligence out there.
At least, not yet.
Despite 60 years of SETI, 30 or 40 years of
astrobiology, 20 years of exoplanet science,
sending landers to other bodies in our own
solar system — nothing.
But, as long as we're able to continue the
search, it's only a matter of time.
Want more science documentaries?
Check out this one right here.
Don't forget to share and keep coming back
to Seeker for more videos.